♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FIRST THEY CAME FOR
YOUR PLASTIC BAGS, THEN THEY
CAME FOR THE PLASTIC STRAWS.
SENSE A THEME HERE?
IF IT IS AN ORGANIC POLYMER AND
IT MAKES OUR LIFE EASIER,
CALIFORNIA IS AGAINST IT.
THE LATEST EXAMPLE, THE CITY OF
BERKELEY TARGETING THE
SINGLE-USE PLASTIC AND PAPER
CUPS.
HAVING SOLVED EVERY OTHER
PROBLEM IN TOWN.
THE CITY COUNCIL PASSED AN
ORDINANCE THAT WOULD REQUIRE ALL
BUSINESSES TO CHARGE CUSTOMERS
$0.25 FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF USING
A DISPOSABLE CUP.
GREG GUTFELD USES DISPOSABLE
CUPS, ALSO HOLDS THE
"GREG GUTFELD SHOW," HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
GREG, THIS SIGNIFIES, LAWS LIKE
THIS, THE VICTORY OVER THE MORE
PROSAIC PROBLEMS THAT MOST
CITIES FACE, LIKE BAD ROBES OR
CRAPPY SCHOOLS, BERKELEY HAS
ALREADY FIXED THOSE.
>> THEY ALWAYS DO THE SAME THIN
THING.
THEY NEVER TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHO
THIS MIGHT HELP OR HURT.
BECAUSE WHO USES PAPER CUPS?
GENERALLY WORKING-CLASS IS GOING
TO GET A CUP OF COFFEE ON THE
STREET, THEY NEVER EXAMINE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTIONS
BECAUSE NONE OF THEIR ACTIONS
WOULD BE ADOPTED.
BECAUSE THERE'S A TERRIBLE!
THERE IS NO PROOF THAT THIS
THEFT -- IT IS THAT -- WILL HELP
THE PLANET.
YOU LOOK AT RECYCLING, FOR
EXAMPLE, NONE OF -- MOST OF THE
RECYCLING, SEPARATING IN BINS,
NOW WE FIND OUT MOST OF THE BINS
AND UP IN LANDFILLS BECAUSE
NOBODY IS ACTUALLY BUYING IT.
THINK OF ALL OF THE TIME COULD
HAVE BEEN BETTER SPENT DRINKING.
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         ST
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         SI
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         SG
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         ST
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         SE
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         S,
INSIDE, WE'RE STAYING         SI
ABSOLUTELY HATED.
I AM FOR RECYCLING, AS YOU KNOW
IF YOU WATCH "THE VIBE COME,"
YOU HEAR MY TALKING POINTS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, BUT IT IS
ECONOMICAL.
RECYCLING IS EXPENSIVE, AND IT
DOESN'T CONTRIBUTE TO A BETTER
PLANET.
NEITHER DOES TAXING THE WORKING
CLASS.
SO IT CAN MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER.
AGAIN, THIS IS ANOTHER VIRTUE
SIGNAL, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IT IS A SYMBOLIC
ACTION THAT DOES NO GOOD.
ISN'T IT ALSO INCREDIBLY
FRIVOLOUS?
IF YOU HAVE A CHILD, AND I THINK
OUR LEADERS SHOULD CARE ABOUT US
AS WE CARE ABOUT OUR CHILDREN, A
CHILD ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND
FAILING OUT OF SCHOOL, FRAGMENT
ANY SEVENTH GRADE, THE REAL
PROBLEM IS I DON'T LIKE THE
SHOE LACES, ISN'T THAT MISSING
THE POINT?
>> THESE ARE EASY THINGS TO
TACKLE.
THERE IS A WEIRD INCLINATION TO
BAN THINGS.
THEY MISTAKE BANNING FOR
PRODUCTIVE ACTION, WHEN IN FACT
IT LIMITS MORE FREEDOM.
LET'S LOOK AT THE PLASTIC STRAW.
DID THEY THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY
DID TO THE DISABLED?
THE DISABLED NEED PLASTIC
STRAWS, AND THEY DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT IS
COLLUDING, THERE IS AN
INTERESTING, 95% OF ALL THE
PLASTIC WASTE IN THE OCEANS
COMES FROM TEN RIVERS, EIGHT ARE
IN ASIA, TWO IN AFRICA.
AMERICA IS NOT POLLUTING THESE
OCEANS, IT IS OTHER COUNTRIES.
YET, WE ARE DOING THIS, HARMING
THE SOCIETY THAT NEED THESE
PLASTIC PRODUCTS.
I ACTUALLY GAVE YOU SOME HARD
NEWS!
>> Tucker: YOU DID, AND I'M
TRYING TO DIGEST IT.
IF THAT IS TRUE, AND I'M TAKING
HER CLAIMS ON FAITH --
>> I MADE IT OUT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T HAVE THE
GOOGLE MACHINE IN FRONT OF ME,
WHY WOULDN'T WE SAY SOMETHING TO
THE COUNTRIES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
POLLUTING THE ENVIRONMENT?
WHY CAN'T WE BE MAD ABOUT THAT?
>> BECAUSE THAT IS NO FUN.
IT IS NO FUN, TUCKER.
WE HAVE TO BE IN THIS LEFT-WING
UNIVERSE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
MEDIA, WE ARE THE OPPRESSORS.
NO MATTER WHAT.
WE ARE AT FAULT, WE HAVE TO PAY
THESE INDULGENCES.
WHEN YOU FIND OUT IT IS CHINA OR
THE PHILIPPINES, EVEN BRAZIL IS
MORE POLLUTING PLASTICS IN THE
OCEAN AND WE ARE, THEN IT IS NO
USE.
YOU CAN'T USE IT POLITICALLY
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES, SO
WHY BOTHER?
IT WAS BACK TO THE ROOT CAUSE,
WHICH IS SELF HATRED.
I DON'T HATE MYSELF, I WOULD
LIKE TO OPT OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: I HATE YOU ENOUGH
FOR YOU.